I don't really want to make this video
but I feel like I have to make this
video I am asked daily when I'm going to
have a third child and if I'm going to
have a third child it's a question I
have received constantly ever since I
started making videos I've always been
on the fence I've gone back and forth a
lot I just have not ever felt quite
ready for that when I had Wyatt I wasn't
ready for him to be my last child I
always knew that but it was a matter of
of just wanting to be in a really really
good place if I were to have another one
so late last year Matt and I kind of
realized that we we were in this ideal
time of having a third we were
financially stable the kids were at a
great age everything was kind of falling
into place so we decided to do it and
boy did that happen quickly oh my gosh
that is such a huge positive oh my
goodness you guys
that's a baby because I'm a little
neurotic I was taking a pregnancy test
every single day and so I found out so
early probably up to two weeks before
the average person who would find out
that they were pregnant I'm not I didn't
celebrate it or anything we have two
other kids where we're still very busy
people
we probably ordered Chinese food that
night and that was the celebration but
we were about very excited I am here at
my first doctor's appointment
that couldn't come because he has a
meeting but we've done this before so I
said I said that's okay I'm excited so
the earliest that they'll usually bring
you in to the doctor to confirm your
pregnancy is at six weeks so when I
found out I immediately called an OBGYN
and I scheduled a six-week appointment
so yeah they weighed me they took my
blood pressure my temperature they asked
a bunch of family health history
questions they asked me about my
lifestyle she asked how many glasses of
wine I used to drink a week and I was
like two but since my neon I have not
had any of course and then they had me
pina cup to confirm the pregnancy but
then it was kind of weird cuz they had
me pee in the cup and then she gave me
an ultrasound anyway and we weren't
expecting an ultrasound because I didn't
think they did it at six weeks so I'm
kind of bummed that Matt didn't get to
be there even though it was literally a
blob but I got to see the little heart
beating beating it's there and it just
it made it so real to me seeing its
heart beating just you know made me feel
like everything was okay and everything
was good I'm really excited I got to see
my little baby today makes it all worth
it all right
decided enough so typically people wait
until the second trimester to tell
anybody that they're pregnant just to
make sure that everything's okay but for
me I was 29 I've had two perfectly
normal pregnancies two healthy kids so I
decided to tell a few close people okay
so alex is coming over for those of you
who don't know she is one of my best
friends and I'm not quite ready to tell
everybody but I'm going to tell her
because she's gonna be so excited okay
oh my gosh what what do you touch to
anything are you pregnant
oh I decided to tell Alex first and
foremost because she comes to my house
almost every weekend and we always have
a glass of wine and she would know
within five minutes if I'm not drinking
wine there's a reason so because this
was my last pregnancy to do everything
right I started planning there were a
few things that I decided I absolutely
needed to do one of which was a
maternity photoshoot so I ordered a
dress which in hindsight is so stupid to
start doing it that early as well as
daily photos of my boat because I never
got any photos of my bump and at that
time in my mind there was not an inkling
of a thought that anything would go
wrong so one evening out of nowhere I
just got these bizarre flu-like symptoms
oh man it's like that crippling nose you
know Neil I can't think about anything
morning sickness isn't actually morning
sickness it can happen at any time
so I took that as a good sign of things
are happening things are progressing you
know so at this point if you don't want
to hear any of the more medical details
of what happened uh skip ahead to this
time in the video so the next morning I
woke up and when I stood up from bed
there was this little pop it was like in
at the base of my uterus almost like a
little just blip with that came a little
bit of pink colored fluid I think that's
fairly normal you usually don't get
concerned until there's bright red blood
but it was weird you know I didn't
really think anything of it and I went
to work and throughout the day at work I
just started feeling worse and worse I I
started to bleed
a little bit at work and then it got a
little worse so I have been spotting um
I started spotting yesterday but it was
like not that bad
today as the day went on it I I noticed
it just slowly started and be more and
it was getting more red in color and so
now I'm and I'm waiting and my mom and
I'm gonna go to the emergency room cuz
my doctor told me to and it's it's like
pouring blood no there's no way I can
fathom that I'm still pregnant hey
there's no way I feel wrong like
documenting this it just I really don't
want to like talk to anybody I wish
someone had talked to me about this so
not stayed with the kids and I went with
my mom to the ER and I got there and it
was very crowded and I waited in the
waiting room for hours by that point I
had started bleeding very heavily I just
remember feeling so embarrassed and
nervous that I was going to get blood
all over my pants so they finally called
me back and turns out they didn't have a
room for me
they had parked a bed next to the
elevator in the hallway I wait I waited
and not bed by the elevator
um I a physician's assistant she asked
me some questions and I was just like
get me out of here I don't want to be
here but at this but I honestly even
asked any questions through this entire
process because I was totally in shock
so they finally wheeled me to get an
ultrasound they did that and they
wheeled me back up and finally a
physician's assistant came and sat next
to me starts reading out loud that I
have no longer pregnant and I knew I was
just trying not to cry and I didn't want
her to keep talking to me she kept
talking about stuff showing me pictures
and shown and I was just like I don't
care oh I wanted to say it I didn't say
that but like in my mind I was like just
nod so she leaves just saying okay okay
okay so I could get out of there when I
got home it was so late because I had
been there for hours and hours so I was
exhausted so after four hours I found
out that I'm not pregnant anymore and
that's I don't know why you cry
like I I saw it I saw it's a heartbeat
and I wanna know what happened
hey I want to know what I did wrong I
don't remember saying that I'm a very
logical person and I need answers
I kept thinking like maybe if I had just
taken it easy after I felt sick that
night maybe if I had gone into work
maybe I you know I took on too much or I
was I was too stressed or I I I needed
to find a reason why and the difficult
part to grasp is that there's no reason
why to this day I still can't shake and
I know it's fully irrational but I still
can't shake the feeling of like well I'm
not supposed to have a third kid and
this was my side so I hope that comes
when it goes away at some point you know
you didn't do anything no not yet
so it's no the second day um since the
yardie day - since the ER woke up in the
night last night with horrible cramps at
like 2:00 in the morning and a migraine
and I couldn't fall back asleep till
like 5:00 so the recovery process took
about two weeks I was bleeding I was
tired
it takes a toll physically and it's it's
very intense it was a blur cuz I went
back to work you know it's not this
thing you can call out sick for for two
weeks cuz it's not something anyone
talks about I just pushed it to the back
of my mind and continued on with my life
also I I have two kids life doesn't stop
I mean just because I went through that
doesn't mean that life stops for me and
they don't have my existing
responsibilities which I think helps
I have not cried today and that is an
accomplishment because if you know me
you know I cry about everything I was
very sad and I felt very stupid I felt
very stupid for just assuming that
everything was okay and everything was
gonna be okay and I could make all these
plans and tell people and buy stuff and
I felt confused about why I didn't see
it coming and why I didn't know what to
look for the thing that has bothered me
the most is that there's no conversation
around this it's not until it happens to
you and you find certain support groups
and people and stuff that that
conversation even comes up I would have
given anything to have just a little
insight a little inkling into what to
look out for so I would HIGHLY encourage
you whether you're pregnant or not or
thinking about it or not or maybe your
your partner is pregnant whatever it may
be please do some research you can go to
this website or you can check any of the
links in the description as of right now
I can't even fathom thinking about you
know trying again or having another
trying for another but at least I'm kind
of at peace with it
with most stories of miscarriage or when
people choose to share their experience
it has a happy ending
well my happy ending I guess is that I
already have two amazing kids and for
now I'm super happy with that and I'm
not saying that I'm ruling anything out
in the future but I'm just saying for
right now I'm not putting any pressure
on myself and I I'm lucky to be able to
make that choice because I know that a
lot of people don't get that luxury so
since that has happened I am still asked
daily if I'm going to have another child
or if I want another child and I know
that no one understands what happened or
knows what happened but this whole
experience has opened my eyes to an
entire world that I didn't even think
about so for anyone out there who has
gone through something similar or is
going through something similar I just
want you to know that you're not alone
and it can happen to anyone having me
[Music]